so back in the day yeah let's say i've
seen like a few things i had a few
things on rotation yeah why do
i see one in the morning yeah so like
let's say not in the morning like 12
o'clock lunch time yeah she come through
yeah then five then she's going around
five o'clock i got my next thing five
o'clock one would leave around nine yeah
and then i get my next thing come from
around 12. no you're actually disgusting
around 12 yeah and then in the morning
i'd say like yo base i've got i got to
go work them times i don't even have a
[ __ ] job
dms
dating apps i don't have time for that i
don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prince i believe in
grilling them i'm going to be going on a
series of dates to find who can really
wow me
this is grilling
big man seniors castillo brev aka the
sniper aka the main event big man
singing i've seen a few people in the
comments asking for me to come back so
men's come through baby get me i'm gonna
be grilling her she ain't gonna be
grilling me you're getting me wet now
bro i don't get worried about nothing
you get me there's nothing she could ask
me there's nothing she could ask me that
i ain't heard before caught cheating too
many times to get stuff out here are you
looking for a relationship
sniper out now on all digital platforms
what's your name cheyenne
yo the mixed race girl name is this nice
okay
yo she's kind of cris still you get me a
nice little light skin tin curly hair
you get me she's a slim thing you get me
but one two three stone it's perfect
brother but i could feed her you get me
well in the ghetto is going on
it took you a while to get here have you
been
what it wasn't [ __ ] this morning then
last night don't know no liar
so you've
had sex with someone and came straight
here yeah have you cleaned your dave of
course can't be walking i have fresh
[ __ ] on my breath that's rude you know
we ain't there yet you get me we're not
we're not there yet but about the woman
did you actually yeah i did for real
bother you bothers me a bit wow you
could have taken one to willy's last
night get me it's not my business this
is what i'm saying this is why it's
scary and this is why i don't like
dating because i just felt everyone's
just moving mad don't worry though i'm
i'm fully drained right now so you know
it's a genuine thing right now i'm
actually trying to get to know you you
get me why are you wearing glasses huh
why because
i don't know if you're confident though
because i feel like you're hiding i'm
here though you're insecure nah i'm very
confident you sure you know what i
noticed here i was in the bar from he
was changing there he had some knickers
on the floor i saw skidmark in there
you're moving man
you're moving mate that's fine i'm not
wearing the kids so you just got your
[ __ ] just out here like wearing jeans
yeah free why not how come why not
because what if like you bend down and
bare people can see your ass cracking
that there's a classy way to bend down
you bend down and you do like that
you know like when you get out of the
car you do the
ah crc lady right say tell me about
yourself i do events
i do music i do all kinds of things fair
things social media pigmenting follow me
on the gram if you ain't yeah what did
you do would you ever do only friends
no never i never say never because you
never know like your life circumstances
are you trying to say you love
circumstances like you've got to be a
struggling [ __ ] i know women that you
know secure the bag and make a lot of
money on it just for me personally i
think the direction that people think
only fans is like sexual content it's
giving it a bad name if that makes sense
yeah yeah you're welcome but yeah you've
got answers
i would do any friends you know i'm not
gonna lie to you like i feel like i mean
best sex tapes and i feel like people
need to see that [ __ ] oh really you know
the ones we just know you're good at
some [ __ ] other people gotta see that
how do you know you're good i can bust
on command really so you come quick nah
like i bust on come on like i'm telling
you for three hours if the thing says
ready to come i come you've got to
control your [ __ ] you get me men's usyk
out there you get me different level and
that's the problem because the male ego
will have you thinking you're good in
bed and you know i know because my willy
drives get crazy
they always come back you've got toxic
dip then big man chin that's the one you
need right there right you've got a girl
they'll pay your rent for that dick
really
rent yeah we'll talk
before now i don't know sugar mama
things things my age paying your rent
big man saying this dick will have your
girl taking out loans
yeah putting things in people's names
brevis mad how much you weigh you think
i don't know you know like you're a
skinny thing in it so like literally
your big things like when you get them
on the floor
lie down flat like that here you get the
leg stretch it all the way back yeah and
you're just pressing up just got the
just driving in drilling it
easy way to make a gas squat oh you do
the next thing you get on top of her put
her feet right there while you're on top
of her while you're when you get your
thumb rub on a quick wait for it to mess
sometimes when it's so bad you will like
fake it so it ends up no no you could
feel it you heard the thing
you know about that little suction thing
in it see that's why you're smiling
you're all right big round that's like
you're smiling
don't know so you toasted that done
get me
so like would you actually look forward
to woman then number one i'm not gonna
lie i'm an appearance person first you
gotta look the part body face back off
all of that yeah i need to be like wow
every time i look at you
next thing is you've got to be secure
within yourself and be able to be by
yourself love your own company you don't
need bare people around you you don't
need to be going out you don't need no
validation to feel good you're good in
your own company i like that [ __ ] so
what's the maddest thing you've done in
bed there was this thing on my facebook
i went to like a yachty wave she
recognized me came up to me we just
started listening right there in a rave
in it and then after that i'm not sure
who this guy was i think this must have
been her baby forever saying in it but
she was of her bridge and i got in the
car her baby father was driving her
bridge and got in the front of me and i
was sitting in the back he drove us to
her yard and he left because they're
having an argument yeah play me enough
the same night but while we were in her
bedroom was in the corner camera just
filming with what we'll talk right so he
knew you know i don't know what then
people was doing but but it was mad if
that was the other way around that would
be a revenge porn situation that's
messed up yes i feel like i'm sexually
abused but it's a bit mad you feel
sexually abused yeah because it was
filming me bro they didn't have my
consent big man senior when i got filmed
it wasn't a thing but man him don't be
filming yell in that brother you get me
brother you end up on the register
i've been there if rkl's eating pot
noodle brev don't do it do women ever
say any stories about you no never bro
i'm not a rapist rev
you know like literally some man is mad
persistent with it yeah you've got to
relax you can read the rum yeah big men
saying you've got to read the room
trying to end up like oh kelly brev now
he's in jail gotta give up his party rev
did you say it so normally about this
like violation thing but as women this
would be very traumatic for us now i'm
not traumatizing about i'm kind of good
my work was amazing though so it's not
traumatizing it's just the fact that
they filmed that [ __ ] i kind of want
them to send that back why it's good
video i want to say i can improve yeah a
little key because you know the ones
there like she was like a ficting as
well in it so like i was putting in some
good work so do you like people watching
if we're filming then yeah but i don't
want nobody watching me like if i was
like somebody's yelling that i wouldn't
want him in the corner of the room like
playing with his dick in that that would
weird me out yeah do you like people to
watch you no you don't like performing
so you never filmed your thing you i
know you filmed your team i know you
filmed your thing never
you know you filmed your team glad you
know you feel what you think you're
pretty i know you filmed your team
i say you're drinking the drink that's
your little key right there and anytime
i say some [ __ ] you drink it i like that
facebook something must have hollered at
me on there i met up with her i went to
see her she drove i don't know where she
lived it was so deep in north i don't
know where it was it's like peanut bread
there's out of the ends hills have eyes
places breath so we went to her yard we
and as soon as we finished
she started smoking crack breath what
yeah she started smoking crack so you
stepped with a crackhead basically and
then after that i just wanted to go to
my yard but i made up for a lie i said
my mom was cooking dinner bro i'll go
get home fast oh my god and she was
driving home but i was just swerving in
the road like oh my god you're so
beautiful i was like [ __ ] you are
crackhead bev take me home yeah it's a
crackhead like i didn't know she was a
crackhead at the time but the [ __ ] was
good you get me but you look like you're
like bad man yeah you look like you're
like a mentalist grab you by the throat
and just mash up your thing i'm not
gonna lie
out of ends in the ends where you from
essex yeah yeah you like the bad man in
it i could tell you like a bad man all
right do you want me to like a bad man i
feel like you do i'll [ __ ] you up though
i'd mess you up
but i just need to know what your level
is i swear what we're talking about is
sex like sex sex sex sex sex sex
so you never had a night with somebody
bear back i know you're [ __ ] if it's
my man
you ever got sti before so you never had
chlamydia no i caught it like four times
in the past i was just in two minutes
the amount of times he has sex i'm not
surprised he's acting media 16 gal just
juggling them around in it like i had
things from birmingham things from like
east north west all them things there
and i was just moving mad but i had like
about five properties and some other
ones that i was just in it i feel like
you've gone ego so you would want me to
come so do you not care about women's
orgasm no no you gotta go first all the
time you've got a bus first all the time
otherwise i'm doing my [ __ ] properly
see amanda actually let someone come
first we'll talk do you know why yeah
because
i need them repeat customers you get me
i need you to less customers i need them
repeat customers because i need you to
get this dick so good you go tell your
brethren so then when this [ __ ] picks up
i can get one of your bridges
do you suffer with mental health
depression in that i feel like to be
fair i've been depressed for a long time
it's social media that saved my life
yeah i was going for a [ __ ] time yeah i
made one social media video went viral
that should change my life but to be
fair
the cure to depression is to figuring
out the root of it my root was being
broke yeah i figured out the root of it
and then that's it but along the way i
had to learn a lot of [ __ ] about myself
what did you learn about yourself you
learn your resilience you learn how
strong you are you learn how to stretch
peace you learn to be [ __ ] on and be
able to come back from that you know to
fall down seven times and stand up eight
times you learn all of that you get me
you learn that that rejection all of
that [ __ ] is nothing rejection is normal
failing is normal yeah i'm trying to say
like i gotta give a shout out to the
people which is like followers on
instagram people say that i don't mean
nothing but for me then people changed
my life like 100 then people lifted me
up of all that [ __ ] yeah because if they
didn't help me i'd be on a mad thing
because i was this close to murking
people but i used to sit on night buses
all day i'd settle night buses in the
night so i want to go insane to keep my
peace of mind i'm trying to say and like
if anybody owed me money or nothing i
would probably do the worst to you yeah
i'm gonna say a few times i try to set
people up just because they try to do
something bad to me it's not a joke
thing this depression thing will make
you
find depths of yourselves that you've
never ever find in your life yeah i'm
trying to say and when you come out from
that though you become a better person
there's nothing wrong with being in a
[ __ ] bro everybody's got to lose their
mind once because then when you find
yourself it's a madness but it's
beautiful you get me that's why i'm
happy all the time now but life is
beautiful i like that cheers to you
so how many people have you live
enough
like over 100
sniper out now on all digital platforms
i think she looks like a
15 to 20 man kind of girl yeah i think
she's about 15 to 20 man you get me
about two free really she said free
relationships
you get me one two holidays brother the
willies pile up brother you do some
addition subtracted next thing you have
twenty bev you get me that's how it is
so back in the day yeah let's say i've
seen like a few things had a few things
on rotation yeah why do
i see one in the morning yeah so like
let's say not in the morning like 12
o'clock lunch time yeah she come through
yeah then fight then she'd go i'm around
five o'clock i got my next thing five
o'clock one would leave around nine yeah
and then i get my next thing come for
around 12. no you're actually disgusting
around 12 yeah and then in the morning
i'd say like yo base i've got i got to
go work them times i don't even have a
[ __ ] job forget me but i'll tell you
all days i've got i gotta go work yeah i
put on my clothes everything like i'm
going to work yeah why don't you say can
you leave because i'm not a horrible
bastard brother that's that's terrible
how could i just tell them to leave like
that that's mad now the only time that
you got a goal is if like you're a crazy
[ __ ] but if you're crazy you've got to
leave my house i mean one time i see a
girl it's like we must have beat fell
asleep four o'clock in the morning she
woke up said she want pizza because she
asked to do something normal four in the
morning
what's happening there's no pizza shops
open at that time the only people out is
crackheads rev so you don't cater to
rooms needs
other than just sections not all the
time you've got okay it's a woman's name
you want love
sniper i know on all digital platforms
the only reason i started getting bear
[ __ ] is because i was fat in school
like about 14 15 i was like 16 17 stone
i got no [ __ ] rev couldn't even see my
willy was mad the maddest thing you
would never believe this if i told you i
lost my virginity at 20. i must have had
like a longtime girlfriend that's my
first basically was together for like a
year and it was so good i was so like
loyal all of that yeah but i swear down
i'd just be online but i've just seen
bear different things i just seen big
back offs fires and all that i was like
yo i need to get some of that rev so i
literally broke up with her after year
and then the day after i broke up offer
i started some next thing from houston
why have you got gold teeth because my
teeth are [ __ ] up
and my real teeth i only got baby teeth
i was raising the caribbean i didn't go
to no dentist or nothing mad poor
brother steal people's toys do their
[ __ ] by the time i come back up here my
teeth was just
when i got some pee i was just like let
me get these top ones in gold and then i
just thought let me go do these bottom
ones in gold yeah yeah but that's the
reason does it taste like girl say just
tastes like metal metal yeah just metal
if i didn't have them right now brother
you'd be like yo my teeth is on some
[ __ ]
nightmare on elm street thing where if
it's mad what's your thoughts on like
toxic masculinity what the [ __ ] is that
big man saying i don't even know what
the hype of masculinity thing is bro but
shout out to my lgbtq people wherever
you get me men being able to be
emotional like um just very self-aware
like if you were upset like what is your
outlet i feel like women say
they want a man that's all sensitive and
all that stuff here and then when he
shows you that you'll think he's a [ __ ]
oh no do you know what it's about
balance because it's like don't get me
wrong if my man's like crying too much
like listen i want my man to be able to
if he's upset we get upset we find out
like we get a solution done don't keep
crying about the same solution so that
that would annoy me it's just about
knowing that you can open up so let me
ask you a question here you're at arabia
yeah i read with your man yeah some
random guy comes by you're like six foot
five aj looking yeah he slaps your bet
yeah your man tries to hype up and he's
like bro shut your mouth bev and then he
slapped the [ __ ] out of your man your
mind don't do nothing then you go home
and you're like babies why don't you do
anything it's like i don't want to get
hurt what would you say to him then when
we have this conversation it's like oh
just because a man cries doesn't make
him a [ __ ] what would you think would
you still give him some [ __ ] after that
yeah see when he's behind you in the
chat and he's like whose [ __ ] is this
who's put you're gonna be like it's
yours babes yeah it's time
and got slapped out but the thing is
though like men have issues within
themselves like a man and a man like the
toxic masculinity that's your own issue
because that's an issue that men need to
work on i can only work on an issue with
my man if that makes sense because i
know that the man reacting like that is
toxic and he has his own trauma the big
man thing more of the story is maddening
don't get slept in front of your gala
but you're your best friend don't do it
what they're never crying funny
no i'm say that this is why there's such
a stigma around men showing emotions
you have a big platform then you can't
say
don't cry again don't do that i think if
you want a normal functioning healthy
relationship you you need to be able to
cry you need to be able to open up
you've got really pretty eyes i like the
way you're just like big man i like the
earrings as well
i'm not gonna lie you know babe she's
chatting bad [ __ ] so i just zoned out
for a bit
i like that but still i do believe
you're like bad man now
so like with your social media platform
do you find that you have some sort of
responsibility for like what you put out
there are certain men that ask me and
certain women ask me for relationship
advice and to me it's a simple answer
but then there's some people they're
going through some real [ __ ] so then
them people there i got a responsibility
to because i know what it's like be
through some hard times in it so like my
thing is this yeah it's a responsibility
in the sense that like i always think
about people's mental health and what
they're going through before i ever take
the piss out him yeah but if it's on
something like you're my use my role
model thing bro [ __ ] you and your
youtube brother i don't care yeah i
ain't a role model to nobody in terms of
people and helping them 100
because like i said then people saved my
life then people got me out nines but if
i had no money universal credit all of
that run out nothing yeah then literally
i'd be like yo who needs promotion did
it somebody sent me a 500 right there
saved my whole life for the month i
definitely owe them people they would
never know how much i owe them like
that's why that's why i never really
ever will ever [ __ ] on social media
thing because like it saved my life
because honestly speaking if it if i
didn't have that i'd definitely be in
jail 100.
[ __ ] yeah i love to eat [ __ ] like
really
yeah i love to eat [ __ ] finally
someone actually eats [ __ ] you know
what it is it's like if you've liked a
woman for a long time like if she's like
you're like your crush like there's
women that like i've crushed hard on
social media yeah facebook instagram all
that then i got with them and i swear
down as soon as we got together brother
as soon as like you got to that moment
yeah i swear down but man this pointed
that like moses but face deep i'm
talking about face deep i'm talking
about yo
i'm talking about straight in there
brother i became an animal i became a
different man well there ain't nothing
wrong with eating some [ __ ] breath
there's nothing wrong with some good
clean naan bread do you get me nothing
wrong with that yeah yeah i'm so good at
it real quick technique about facing it
tongue it sucked
he gave me switch the tongue all the way
around it baby if you get me all the
juices and all that [ __ ] where it's like
a passion fruit i love that [ __ ] so the
right technique still it's all right
give them some ratings there
other than sex as you have a lot of it
what else do you like to do i like
giving people advice i like helping
people yeah yeah i mean i love doing
music that's my main thing snipe out now
in all digital platforms and that you
get me but like i love helping people
brother like you get me i love helping
people like i do like relationship
advice i get people dming me like wait
wait wait wait you give relationship
advice yeah yeah what kind of person is
taking relationship advice off this man
we'll talk no no no no no talk i'm not
lying like literally like a few years
ago some girl dm me like she said that
her man was a crush dresser and she
started sending me pictures of him and
he was wearing dresses and he was
wearing her shoes in that you get me and
i just i just told her like yo man's
just living his life expressing himself
in it if you're not down with it you
can't do [ __ ] so then me and i linked up
like a week later
no this is what i'm saying that's not
advice that's just like nobody helped
her brother a man weren't giving her no
dick that's mad all right it's the
private space for you no but he's the
private herb like she's going insane
brother man's wearing how he was in that
that's man
do you not want love snipe out now on
all digital platforms bev what do you
want out of life i want peas with yeah i
want money that's what i want money just
money yeah they loved him money's worth
so you don't want love no no no because
your heart's been broken yeah a few
times a few times
do you feel like you've been burned so
many times you're just not on it now do
you know what it is here i'm on a length
and yell down thing right now rev i'm
not gonna lie it's just about laying
down the gelding right now but if i just
feel like rather this willy's gotta be
shared but i just got a link down the go
that dick is not going anywhere near me
do you not think you've done it enough
nah beth i've got to explore the world
web this is london it's a bigger world
where it's brazil
brother france sweden yeah russia mayor
tingsman you ever gonna settle down like
when are you gonna be like right that's
it
yeah how annoying you are
what advice do you give guys to get laid
it's three things yeah
number one look presentable
yeah you get me go get yourself a decent
haircut if you're a fat bastard go gym
some men can't pull it off you get me
yeah that's number one get your
appearance down you get me you don't
want to be scared enough to kill them
yeah number two be confident about your
[ __ ] it don't matter if you're broke
don't matter if like you're a top waist
man you can make it work a lot of men
that are super waste man they get yelled
you just need a bit of confidence yeah
and number three don't overthink the
thing yeah a lot of men think that
chatting to a girl is a big thing like
approaching a girl is a big thing you
just gotta look at it like this don't go
in there with no motives even trying to
go in there to get [ __ ] are matting
just go on there on some get to know the
person thing and everything will fall
into place it's when you try and force
it and try and have an objective try and
have a motive try and have some sort of
end goal
you're going to show your card straight
away gala is going to see through that
so you're trying to get [ __ ] see you
ain't got no confidence and it's gone
let's strike up a regular conversation
if you get rejected
there's big yell out here it's not that
deep are you a family man nah bro i
don't give a about family my whole life
has just been me and my mom i don't care
about family both of my parents
had a one night standby in a crack house
they made me they both got schizophrenia
my mum my gran adopted me that's just me
and my mom and that's all it is that's
all i give a [ __ ] about mom's like 83
years old yeah and when she passes
that's it brad i'm not gonna be on a
super mad thing but yeah
but yeah
when it comes to the family i don't want
to see like grandkids and stuff i don't
know man but like have you ever had that
conversation genuinely does she know how
active you are like yeah yeah my mom
used to meet beg yeah my mom used to
meet bear girl back in the day but has
she has she ever just been like you know
what like settle down meet a nice woman
and she told me not to get none of these
things pregnant right but actually i
don't get none of these things pregnant
you're moving mad i remember my dad at
23. yeah he never knew about me and i
never knew about him because it was a
one-night stand thing in it like
literally this met there was an elin
they had a one-night stand that must
have been the best [ __ ] had in his life
but because like literally they made me
in it so like after that it's
disappeared but it's not his fault
though he get me he did his thing when
they were selling drugs in and out of
prison and all that stuff and then he
come out of prison he was in prison for
like seven years then he come out and my
grandson on a bus she said like you know
you got a son
and he was like what then he grabbed my
granny throw against the wall and he off
the bus and he ran down the stairs but
then they made the connection or
whatever and then i met him but yeah
he's right man he's right
so if i'd slept with a hundred men
how do you feel about that i feel like
you need to get some professional help
with come with the same energy that you
come with yourself then in it like i'm
fine with people's body count i
generally don't have an issue with your
body count why do i have to be virgin
mary it's like only fans get the only
fans i'm all fooled actually i love that
[ __ ] i think you should do that but for
the wifey man can't do that bro because
like look at this like look at it then
why should i make you my husband that's
what i'm saying i think no you're
involved
so what's acceptable for you i don't
think about girls body accounts i'll
never ask i'd rather not know i'm never
going to ask you i don't want to know
that [ __ ] how can you be my wife my
queen
my soul mates
these times men can see your [ __ ] for
4.99 a month
netflix is 10 pounds brev yeah but
netflix is 10 pounds that means my
girl's [ __ ] is worth less than netflix
smith that's mad do you reckon you ever
will just sit with just one woman and
not she be with her
she's like i don't know all digital
platforms i hate honestly i hate you
you're so hard to have a conversation
with so i'm going to take that as a no
no on all digital platforms i feel like
this is a front and this is why you've
got your glasses on and i think that
it's like an insecurity thing in the
nicest way
you have
good intentions but you just choose not
to and it's a shame and that's why i'm
not falling for that bad boy storyline
that i could make you change you're just
toxic busy [ __ ] pigmenting cheers to the
toxicity and that don't know
yeah
no really [ __ ] no
that [ __ ] makes my dicks off better than
never really once again like did you
follow me no oh okay busting a [ __ ] on a
madness like that nobody like
get some vip spray that [ __ ] in the
toilet after you're done with you get me
like don't be out here just [ __ ] up
the place right it's not wrong it's
normal bro but that whole fighting and
burping [ __ ] that's the first way to put
me off like i will cheat on you so quick
red flag literally so quick i just feel
like that's mad disrespectful like
fighting and burping in front of me like
what the [ __ ] is this
yeah but it's still like fine and
birthing like it's like i'm not your
child man really that is pathetic mate
bro a girl cannot fight around me for a
stinky betty rabbit it's not happening
i want i want a best friend though i'm
saying i want my man's my best friend
what it is i'll be honest if you like
once you fight in front of me you can
never try and be sexy the moment you put
on like lingerie now i'm just looking at
you like right look at this stink betty
galbraith for a smelly bum rev
no yeah sorry it depends on it if like
if you've got some [ __ ] kids bro just
like no breath if you get me i've had
times where when i gail's house one time
i was at gayle's house i held i held the
girl's hand and my son literally brought
me through a plastic chair at me but i
was like yo
dear kid
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] for a plan to
check me but if the kids are nice then i
say yeah all the way i don't mind when
you get to a certain age like you're
gonna have to expect a girl has kids
breath you get me so it's not a problem
unless your kids are [ __ ] you can't
call kids [ __ ] yeah you can rev
there's a lot of [ __ ] dukes out
there bev bear them
yeah
yes or no some girl like
you need to give them that cut off for
life otherwise they're always going to
think it's a thing and then if i get off
a new woman i never want you ever
thinking that you're some competition to
her like you're dead beth right now you
can never be anybody to her you're
nobody to her you can't just be
lingering in the back you need to know
that this is the upgrade wherever you
want to knock your 5110 there's an
iphone 15 ain't no there's no comparison
yeah
was a good friend though yeah but that's
some old [ __ ] brother we aren't [ __ ]
with that no more i don't mind because i
think for me i've never really had a
toxic end to relationships
but what about your new guy like you
just now but there's a boundary joe i'm
saying i'm never going to have my man
look stupid i'm not embarrassing my man
i'm he's not really but even his chance
yet x-men is a bit of a violation like
just knowing the fact that you're
chatting to the next man that had his
will in your mouth it's mad you get me
and then i'll be happy
hell no if it's a serious thing nah man
you're going to be chatting today man
yeah all the time grab that's standard
yeah sucking toes is blessed
not so much
no but i've had yellow suck my toes
before yeah if you've got a nice feet
it like it's like it hits you in
different places like you feel tingles
it's like yeah licking your nipples on
that it's like yo it's a bit zesty but
it hits the spot you get me yeah that's
nice and if a girl's got pretty toes as
well it's amazing like when you're
sucking a girl's toes
getting me i got mad like i put my
tongue between the nail baby toe all of
that [ __ ] yeah i love that [ __ ]
is there anything you're embarrassed to
admit no not really no you know what it
is i've gone through some stop sharing
it so then you know when you go through
some mad [ __ ] like you gotta be you
gotta be super like open like i've had
times when i've been super broke a tin
came to my yard you go to the shower you
gotta wear shoes to the shower because
the the floor soaked
i was living in a mad place there's
maggots on the floor like things that
you had to see the magnets on the floor
you can't say [ __ ]
i feel like you're really desensitized
to like
things like i don't know i've got to
live life in it like just because it's a
bit [ __ ] i'm not gonna get like it's
person enough in it i gotta find little
ways to make myself smile well we
actually think she is about trisha
goddard in that rap she thinks he's a
therapist long
what if my ex was after you if it's over
guiller he needs to [ __ ] off but if he's
got a personal problem with me i'd have
to mash him up but if it's over you i'm
beefing over you rev why what if we were
together i'm beefing over that's dead
can't be forever yeah apparently when i
asked you that when you gave me your
scenario yeah so now there's no beef
over girl no you shouldn't be
i'd have a problem with him coming to me
not with you because i'm not beefing
over again but on a man level if he
crosses like if he's trying to cross
that line i have to mash him up that's
man okay so what if we were out then i'm
your woman and someone touches me in the
club what are you doing about it i'd
have to mash him up because now you're
disrespecting me it's not even about you
you think i'm a [ __ ] oh that's why
you're doing that only fans is off the
cards then no no i'll link a girlfriend
offense it's not gonna be no
super relationship thing bro because
like i said if only fans the levels
escalate one minute is to show the
nipple you get me next thing you know
you're trying to charge men a
subscription of 20 pound for you to suck
willy on their breath two years later
now you're trying to show man your whole
uterus brev giving birth on there
man now that means as soon as my youth
enters the earth as soon as he comes
into the world he's already a waste man
rap because his mum's moving mad
can't have that yeah what if i genuinely
want to involve other people in our sex
life if it's another gyal cool if you
try to bring mandom in there it's a
whole another mad thing that
now you're just violating me on next
level now i gotta watch the next man
[ __ ] the [ __ ] of you while i'm there in
the back just watching like a victim rev
what is the problem with having a man so
man's gonna be drilling you out and i'm
like looking at man's ball bags clapping
off your bum cheeks that's mad that's
going to give me ptsd now i'm insane so
seeing the next man's ball back he's
clapping against your bottom lip man now
i'm just watching
matting if it's another girl it's cool
but the girl has to be on your level you
get me you can't be bringing those super
fat [ __ ] built like a snowman to me but
it's dead i like big things if you're
built like a snowman it's there's
there's thick i like big and curvy super
big and curvy you could be 16 17 18
stone and curvy but if you're built like
a like a raspberry
it's not happening bev can't just be out
here built like a minion rev what is
this
what because that's gonna make me laugh
no because that's gonna make my dick
soft breath if your belly is bigger than
your bum
come on now what that's some biggest
loser [ __ ] now but how's your belly
sticking out further than your bum
that's mad
you're built like tyson fury brev that's
mad
what if i earned more money than you i
don't mind that that's all good with me
most girl i've ever dated earn way more
than me way more i like that [ __ ] that
means that you're about saying you get
me you can elevate me on some next [ __ ]
and inspire me and motivate me to get on
your level i love that [ __ ] nice
how do you think you've done on the date
i don't really give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna
lie about because i know that i did good
you get me i know that i'm a spice so
regardless how it goes i don't give too
bad but i'm gonna leave there get some
[ __ ] anyway so
i had a great time okay how about you
you have a good time that was in the
right time no no i like that thank you
shin you're getting me
i think it was a great day you get me
like i left the house i was in a good
mood came out here it was a nice day had
some wine some good conversation it was
nice he was honest so i can't knock him
he was an honest guy but
that was awful like who talked about sex
so much she was cute i like her vibe
there was definitely not a second date
if she put on about two freestone i
would definitely date her again i think
he handled the grinning well although
like i felt i couldn't really grill him
i just was trying to like
comply i wanted him to confine to me you
know i think i did well you know i feel
like throughout the whole thing
i got to know a bit well you get me so
it was nice i thought i did good the
moment you walked in i thought i thought
you know what let me just ride it out it
surprised me that she was a bit nervous
still she looked a bit rattled not gonna
lie
i think what impressed me the most
was his honesty because i genuinely like
an honest man but however it didn't
actually impress me what was coming out
of his mouth
big man singer i think she's definitely
gonna rape me a 10 breath if you get me
i'm the main event how could she not
ten i think some of that crack rubbed
off on him
that girl definitely likes bad boys but
i'm telling you man them
bad man
hit her up brother i'm telling you she's
on there
this is a very generous
like score that i'm going to give him i
felt like he was opening up and honest
and i always want an honest man but
he has way too much trauma going on and
i'm not trying to mother him like i just
want a partner so i'm going to give him
a free
[Music]
you